et pour finir ce 7,8 de jeudi deux
invités qui m'ont rejointe en plateau
mighty o'gleman bonsoir avec vous on va
parler dans quelques instants
d'amour beaucoup beaucoup d'amour et
doré qui seul un bon soir avec vous on
va parler pas d'amour en parler de coeur
on va parler notamment des gestes qui
sauvent
voilà c'est pour faire le lien entre
entre vous deux alors il ya une
opération qui s'appelle sentez vous
sport à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin samedi et dimanche et des
activités sportives qui sont ouvertes à
tous cette façon gratuite
un petit coup de pub du saut à
l'élastique à la marche nordique box ou
du biathlon et puis à côté de ce village
du sport il ya un village santé auquel
participe la croix rouge puisque vous
allez montrer les gestes qui sauvent
c'est là seulement sur le dimanche de
10h à 17h30 18h nous ferons un certain
nombre de petites démonstrations comme
des démonstrations sur comment on traite
l'arrêt cardiaque
qu'est ce qui se passe quand t'es rien
quand nous intervenons sur un accident
de moto il y aura des simulations il y
aura des petites animations de ce type
là toute la joie c'est important parce
qu'on estime qu'en france c'est que 10 à
12% de la population qui est formée aux
gestes de premiers secours tout à fait
tout à fait un grand chauve quoi bannu
nous essayons de faire notre part de ce
côté là en réalité il ya peut-être un
peu plus de 10% maintenant parce que
tous les jeunes qui passent dans les
jmps reçoivent automatiquement dans les
collégiens dans les journées d'appel aux
cégeps moi j'aime prcg à pdg ap dévoile
exactement à force de jouer séjournent
les journées dallas 21 défense la
reçoivent une formation qui est donnée
par la croix-rouge d'ailleurs et puis
l'année dernière ont fait d'autre part
avec la capitale de secourisme on nous
informait plus de 500 personnes l'action
de traitement du massage cardiaque
nous referons des démonstrations
dimanche nous referons des petites
sassus compliqué de faire un massage
cardiaque de pratiquer un massage
cardiaque non pas très compliqué c'est
très important de le faire très vite dès
l'instant où quelqu un malaise cardiaque
c'est pas difficile de servir d'un
défibrillateur mais quand on sait que
les secondes des seconds
c'est un bon qu'elle a irrigué pendant
une minute ça peut entraîner des effets
directs fils dans le massage de dans la
crise cardiaque la rapidité
d'intervention multiplient d'une manière
exponentielle les chances de survie et
les chances de ne pas avoir de séquelles
donc c'est pour ça qu'on voit une
multiplication d'installations
défibrillateur à droite et à gauche
sessegnon d'avoir le gaucher el-ater
mais quand on a quelqu'un qui ferme à
lescar délai côté de soi il faut quand
même savoir s'en servir mais à voir la
panique et sur la voie si on perd déjà
dix minutes à lire d'un autiste
d'instruction c'est vrai qu'on a perdu
beaucoup de temps on a perdu tous les à
côtés
donc c'est là où nous intervenons pour
essayer de former le maximum de
personnes
c'est une des activités que nous
présentons dimanche l'idée c'est de
démontrer un peu tout ce qui est fait
par notre équipe principalement de
secouriste de manière à pouvoir
éventuellement générer quelques
vocations supplémentaires parce qu'en
plus vous recruter des bénévoles dans
l'idée c'est de recruter des bénévoles
aussi oui bien sûr parce que nous avons
beaucoup de demandes pour été pour faire
des postes de secours dans les
manifestations qui se produit sur la
ville nouvelle et il ya dieu qu'il y en
a beaucoup et donc malheureusement banos
bénévoles sont pas taillables et
corvéables à merci donc on en ferait
qu'on renforce un peu cette équipe ils
sont déjà vous êtes vous savez combien
de personnes actuellement dans une
trentaine de bénévoles secouristes qui
interviennent dans les postes de secours
c'est vrai que j'aimerais que l'on fixe
pas de limite à la divine providence et
ont doublé le nombre de bénévoles ça
serait pas aimer pour devenir bénévole à
la croix-rouge
les gens doivent se dire il faut ni
compétence non parce que la croix rouge
c'est pour ça que nous faisons des
formations aussi au grand public nous
avons des cellules de formation très
intensive et très professionnelle
justement pour préparer les bénévoles
larron joue avec la santé des gens donc
on peut pas se permettre ou ne devient
pas secouriste jour notamment aux est
dangereuse et le court il cédait pour ça
que les gens disent oh ben non moi je
souhaite devenir mais l'évaluation la
notion d'un secouriste va l'apprendre
aux six mois et un an avant qu'on
commence à lui laisser prendre des
responsabilités
un chef d'intervention chef de
dispositifs ça va prendre entre deux et
trois ans quand on veut devenir bénévole
à la croix rouge c'est possible même si
on n'a pas des cons des compétences en
rangée en gestes qui sauvent n'a pas de
l'éducation sanitaire de médecine
personnes
non notre but n'est pas de remplacer les
médecins ni même les infirmiers c'est de
savoir faire le geste qu'il faut éviter
le geste qu'il ne faut pas faire parce
que c'est souvent le plus important et
puis prendre les précautions pour mettre
une personne en situation d'attenté
savoir bien expliqué au médecin du samu
aux médecins mais ça c'est important
gentil sts la situation les symptômes et
à appliquer éventuellement les mesures
d'urgence qui sont à prendre
donc tout ça on pourra découvrir ce à
l'occasion non ça ce dimanche là donc
c'est un aussi un peu ludique de roncq y
aura un stand photo il y aura des petits
tombola il y aura des petites petites
animations organisées pour rendre la
chose la plus attrayante possible donc
ça se passe à la base de loisirs de
saint quentin vous serez présent que le
dimanche on sera présent les miens
ajouté et en dehors donc de cette
présentation qui a lieu dimanche donc la
croix rouge assure aussi des formations
pendant toute l'année ça je te fais qui
s'adressent alors pas forcément à ceux
qui veulent devenir bénévoles mais aussi
au grand public ou aussi au grand public
voilà donc c'est sur demande nous nous
recherchons d'ailleurs des formateurs
parce que si on avait suffisamment de
formateurs on ferait des formations deux
fois par semaine ou presque
actuellement on en fait péniblement une
ennemie par mois à peu près mais aussi
dans les entreprises dans les grandes
entreprises nous sommes sollicités dans
les entreprises mais nous avons
une structure spécifique pour tout ce
qui est professionnel donc et qui est
géré par des professionnels d'ailleurs
de la croix rouge c'est notre mais c'est
sur le plan départemental qu'on organise
ça nous sur le plan local on s'occupe
des particuliers d'accord merci beaucoup
vont rester en place avec nous ou tout à
fait valoir et on les aime